this is lecture 23 of cs229
um so uh today we're going to just
continue
the the uh finals review that we started
last class
and uh we'll finish up the final review
and ah that's going to be it so
uh we we might finish a little early
today
all right um continuing the the uh
the final reviews so in the last class
we started off with supervised learning
we we we kind of again went through
linear regression all the different
interpretations of linear regression
ah such as minimizing the square laws
the probabilistic interpretation the
projection interpretation the normal
equations
and then we moved on to logistic
regression which is
a model that you can use for
classification logistic regression
outputs of probability
for each for each example of ah the
probability that the
the ah the class is equal to one and
then you can use a threshold and convert
it into a classifier
and then we spoke about newton's method
ah which is another optimization problem
that works well for convex or concave
problems
and the the key summary from newton's
method is that it can be very efficient
in terms of converging quickly but
newton's method is kind of plug and play
which means it
automatically performs optimization you
don't need to specify
whether you want to maximize a function
or minimize a function you just throw a
function at it and it optimizes
by finding the nearest stationary point
which means if your function is concave
convex
then it automatically minimizes it for
you if it's concave it automatically
maximizes it for you if it is neither
convex or concave it just takes you to
the nearest
nearest stationary point right that was
newton's method
moving on so there was this other
algorithm that we saw called the
perceptron algorithm
right so the perceptron algorithm was a
streaming algorithm
by streaming we mean it is an algorithm
where you encounter one example at a
time
you know think of it like stochastic
gradient descent where you are
encountering one example at a time
right and the perceptron algorithm had a
very simple update rule
which was theta equals
theta plus alpha times
y minus
g of theta transpose x
right where g was just an indicator
function
which would return 1 if theta transpose
x is greater than equal to 0
or it would return 0 if theta transpose
x was
less than 0. so this is the indicator
function which returns 1
if z is greater than equal to 0
return 0 if z is less than 0 right
and the the idea here was that supposing
you have some examples let us lets use
some colors
so let us say you have some positive
examples
right and you have some negative
and for our purposes suppose this is the
origin
and you have a theta vector that's
currently pointing in some direction
right generally you want theta the theta
vector
to point in the direction of your of
your positive class
so the the intuition behind the way um
the perceptron algorithm works is that
if
your answer is correct that is if theta
transpose x is greater than or equal to
zero
then this whole term evaluates to zero
if you make correct prediction
right and so you you don't change your
um
you don't change your parameters at all
however if you make a mistake that is if
the
correct answer was 1 and you predicted
the 0
that means that you want to
uh this will then end up i forgot
x here right this will then end up
adding a small
small scalar times x to your parameter
vector
right which means if this is
where a theta is pointing and the new
example ah
x is let us say over here
over over here then the
decision boundary of the current
parameter
vector would be something like
this and
let's say the uh make it easier let's
say
the the example
was here and so the the uh
the decision boundaries like this and so
this this example is now predicted as a
negative
because it is it is on the other side of
the decision boundary
so what we want to do is now is to take
this x vector
this is the x vector which got
mis-classified right
take a small for a small scalar times
this
x vector and add it to
theta vector so which means you add a
small component
right so the we call this alpha times x
and now this becomes the updated
parameter vector
right and in this updated parameter
vector for for this
the separating hyperplane which is
perpendicular to it
this would be the updated separating
plane and now we see that
the x is now correctly classified right
so the the general idea
here the the larger take home message is
that
when you want some vector theta vector
to take a value that's that's closer or
is
oriented closer to some desired vector
then a thing you can do or an obvious
thing you can do
is to add a small scalar times the
vector
to the desired vector right that is
theta plus alpha times x
dot product with x
will always be greater than theta
transpose x right that's that's that's
the take uh take home summary that you
want to add a small
scalar times a vector to theta to make
theta be oriented closer to uh closer to
x
and that's the perceptron algorithm
adding vector vectors make them make
them similar that's
that's the take home message and we saw
uh in fact you you also implemented the
perceptron algorithm in ah
i think it was homework two where um we
took this algorithm and then kernelized
it and and
ah you guys also you know plotted the
separating boundaries and whatnot
right so that was that was perceptron
and in the perceptron algorithm
there is theory which we did not cover
in the course but there is theory to
show that
ah if a separating hyperplane does exist
then no matter in what order you present
the examples to the learning algorithm
it will eventually find some separating
hyperplane
right that was that was ah that was the
the
property of perceptron algorithms that
no matter what what order you present
the examples in your stream
as long as you as you follow this update
rule if there is a
separating hyper plane it will end up
recovering that hyper plane and once you
get
a a separating hyper plane all the
updates beyond that point
will always be zero sorry so it would
have converge to
one of the one of the possible
separating hyperplanes
and after ah the perceptron we moved on
to something called the exponential
family
so exponential family
is a family of probability distributions
which have the general form p of
y parameterized by eta is equal to
b of y times
exponent of
eta transpose t of y
minus a of eta right
where y is the is the ah
is the variable y is the variable
t of y is called the sufficient
statistic
statistic and for most of the uh
problems that we considered especially
with our generalized linear models
t of y would mostly be equal to y for
the purposes of our class
right so uh t of y is the sufficient
statistics
statistic eta is called the natural
parameter
natural
parameter and b of y is called the base
measure
and a of eta is called the log partition
function
right and this exponential family
covers many different kinds of variables
exponential families can can um
encompasses discrete random variables
continuous random variables positive
only random variables
integer random variables
it it it is pretty pretty flexible in
terms of the different kinds of supports
the random variable can have and so
as a consequence when we define a
generalized linear model
generalized linear model where we take
an exponential family
and set eta equals theta transpose
x where theta is now your learnable
parameter
learnable parameter that we learnt
through
gradient ascent or design and xs are the
inputs that correspond to y
right once we once we kind of connect
the inputs
and outputs using this linear model
then the the generalized linear model
can therefore be is is is this more
general form of regression
classification
you know poisson regression etc where
depending on the
data type of y or the support of y we
get all these different
different different models
for example when y is just a real value
you get regression
when y is binary between 0 and 1 you get
a classification
right and and
based on based on this relation of how
we
extend exponential family to generalize
linear model
where this is the linear model the
sufficient
the natural parameter is is set equal to
ah theta transpose x we get these
um we get these ah we also showed these
special properties
so first of all the expectation
of t of y
or in general just the ah expectation
of y where where t of y equals y
is equal to a prime of eta
that is the derivative of the log
partition function
at eta evaluated eta
and similarly the variance
of y or variance of ah
or t of y is equal to the second
derivative
a double prime of eta
right you showed this in ah homework one
ah
problem four right and the these
these two results can be extended to
generalize linear models as well
right so in generalized linear models
expectation
of y given x parameterized by theta
is now a prime of
theta transpose x times x
right it is a simple simple extension
from from from
exponential family to glm so this is
exponential family and this is
glm and similarly the variance
of y given x parameterized by theta
is now a double prime of theta transpose
x times x x transpose
right and using this property we showed
that
generalized linear models are
are what we what we showed is that
this term over here
is also the
hessian of the log likelihood so the
hessian of the log likelihood works out
to be
this particular formula or in fact it's
going to be the sum over all the
x i's and from this made
this this term we can see that the
hessian is always
some um
think i wrote it the other way
this should be on the right so what we
showed was that
a double prime of um
a double prime of y
of sorry of r
of eta will be the variance of
y given x parameterized by theta
times x x transpose yeah and ah
and here this will be uh a prime
of of
x of theta will be
will be ah the expectation of
of y given x
times
times x right so what we see is that ah
the it can be shown that the uh the the
hessian of your log likelihood will
evaluate to this
and this is always positive
because it's the variance and this is
psd
right so the hessian of the log
likelihood of a generalized linear model
will always be positive semi definite
and therefore convicts
this question
essentially
so glm is when we um
we take an exponential family right and
re-parameterize the natural parameter
with the covariates of corresponding to
that example
so that takes us from exponential family
to glm in exponential family
you only have y's there is no x's there
right
if you want to use it as you know some
kind of a predictive model where given x
you want to predict y
this exponential family alone does not
work because you you have only y
right and the way you introduce your
inputs is by
re-parameterizing the natural parameter
as theta transpose x
where x's are the are the inputs
corresponding to y
and theta are the learnable
benefit does parameters parametry
parameterization give you over
uh for example feature transform feature
maps
so feature a good question so feature
maps uh is kind of orthogonal to this
so you can still use feature maps where
instead of theta transpose x
you do theta transpose phi of x
so you can you can introduce feature
maps into generalized linear models uh
so it's a separate concept introducing
feature
feature maps what what our glm allows
you to do is is
provide you a way to connect wises wise
with xs
right without without without a glm you
you have only y's there's no x's in in
exponential
sure that i'm understanding this family
maybe taking offline
so in why
so this is this is eta equals theta
transpose x
so it it means that we assume that
eta or the natural parameter is equal to
theta transpose x
and then y is sampled from the
exponential family that has this eta
right that's where the noise comes in so
y is going to be a noisy version
noisy observation and the noise follows
this exponential family
and the parameter of the exponential
family will be theta transpose x
right once once you once you evaluate
theta transpose x you get an eta
which will determine the exponential
family and from that you assume that
the y is going to be a sample from that
exponential family
so that's that's exponential families
and then we saw this
this
and then we saw this connection later in
the course
between exponential families and maximum
entropy
right so performing maximum likelihood
on exponential family so um
if you are given a data set um
y i you know i
equals 1 1 through n and you perform
mle with some
exponential family that is equivalent
to performing maximum entropy that is
max h of p
with the constraint that the
expectation of some some
statistic functions t of y
is equal to the
sample sample averages i equals one to n
t of y i subject to this constraint
if we maximize the entropy then
you the the solution that you get will
lie in the exponential family
and the parameters of that exponential
family will be the ones
will be the same parameter that you get
by performing maximum likelihood
on the exponential family and the
sufficient statistics that you used for
the constraints
are going to be the sufficient
statistics of that exponential family
right so that's that you know it's it's
this duality result
where you can you know maximum
likelihood and maximum entropy are like
these
dual problems of each other right so
that was
maximum likelihood and maximum entropy
and then we moved on to something called
generative models
well so maximizing the
entropy subject to these constraints
is the same as maximizing the likelihood
of this data set
using an exponential family that has
sufficient statistics equal to these
functions
and then we move on to something called
generative models
generative models so the algorithms
until then
that we studied were modeling p of
y given x x was considered given right
we did not assign any kind of
probability distribution to x's right
they were given but we we
ah we would assign some kind of a
distribution to to y
and then with with generative models
we now instead try to so this was our
discriminative models
right in discriminative models we just
model p of y given x
whereas in generative models
we actually try to model x as well right
so our interest here is p of y comma x
which is generally written as p of x
given y
times p of y right so this is
the joint and over here
p of y we generally call it the prior
and if y is discrete we call it the
class prior
and p of x q and y you can ah think of
it as the likelihood function
right so um we model both
both y's and x's are x given ys
and depending on the the data type of x
we could either so xs could either be
real valued
real valued right
for example in gda y
was x was x was real valued or
x could be discrete discrete value
right and we saw one example of discrete
valued x which was naive bayes
right so these are these are these two
generative algorithms that we saw
where both these generative algorithms
have
discrete y's so the ys are discrete in
both these versions ah
in both these examples which means in a
way we are trying to perform
classification because your ys were
discrete right
but the x is in one one ah in one case
in gda
x was real valued and in the other case
in ni base x was discrete valued
and for gda
the the model was something like this so
we assumed
p of y the prior was some bernoulli
bernoulli with ah parameter phi
and p of x given y
was from some kind of a normal
distribution
with mean mu y so each y
had its own mu and a common covariance
matrix
sigma right so this was this was a gda
and the kind of picture to have in your
mind
is in g d a we have
some x's so so ah
some some some x's that come from y
equals
zero so let us just call them zero
that that have some kind of a covariance
structure sigma
right
so this ellipse kind of you know
uniquely
determines the the covariance sigma and
then there is
another another class y
so this corresponds to y equals 0
y equals 0 and for y equals 1 we have
this other
that has that is
so the assumption is that y equals 1
also
is distributed according to a gaussian
with the same covariance structure as y
equals 0
right so this is y equals 1
right so this is this is the picture to
have in about gda where
um until we we uh studied generative
algorithms we were not even visualizing
x right
so we would only focus on you know what
y was we would plot
um you think of think of
y and and modeling y but now we are
trying to assign
probabilities to exit x directly right
so this is
x1 x2 x1 or xt
and because of this equal covariance
the the posterior of p
of y given x p of y given x
takes a form of one over one plus
exponent of minus something
right and thats because its its easy to
see that
if both of them have this this ah
equal covariance structure and suppose
both of them have an equal number of
examples
then the line that or the the set of all
points
that gets equal likelihood both from the
class 1 gaussian and the class 2
gaussian
is going to be some straight line right
and and that kind of corresponds to
a form which can be expressed as a
logistic regression because
in logistic regression we also got
linear separating boundaries
right now if the equal covariance
assumption is not met
so instead if we had a normal with
mu a mean corresponding to the class and
also covariance corresponding to the
class
then we would have gotten instead norm
ah
one covariance that looks like this
another covariance probably looks like
this
right and now the set of all points that
get equal likelihood under both these
classes
would probably look something like this
right it wouldn't be a straight line
anymore
it would be a quadratic right
so that's that's gda the posterior of
the gda is ah
is a logistic takes on a logistic
regression form
you saw that in ps1 q1
right and we also
kind of briefly discussed you know what
are the cases when you want to
use logistic regression directly and
what are the cases when you want to
use gda yes question
why did we make that assumption of equal
covariance
like we know how to do mle with uh
different covariances
was it just to show that you get a
logistic as a
as your posterior or i'm guessing you
well so in this case um so the question
is do we get a logistic as a posterior
in this case
uh you can show that you do get a
logistic uh as a posterior in this case
but
that logistic will have quadratic form
quadratic features of xs
right so you can show that this this
takes on a logistic regression form
except that
the the uh it's a logistic where you
include quadratic features of your xs
and why did you assume initially that
you have the same code
so so uh so so the the question of why
we assume something
the answer is always if you assume
something you get this
right and and you know why you assume
something is
most of the times it's because it gives
you some kind of a mathematical
convenience
and then you kind of measure up against
real data whether the assumption was
reasonable or not
right that's that's in general that's
going to be the answer for why we assume
something for anything you know most
in this course and in general right you
know making some assumptions
gives you you know some kind of
mathematical convenience may be you know
easy to implement or you know convexity
or whatever
and that assumption may or may not hold
true and then
so you make that assumption you know
build a model or whatever and then you
fit your data and see if that assumption
was valid or not
this question um
yeah so i'm coming i'm coming to that uh
right away so then we kind of uh um
kind of uh ask the question you know
what under what some circumstances do we
want to use logistic regression
and when do we want to use gda right and
the
the the answer to that is if you don't
have a lot of data
and also if you are pretty sure
that the modeling assumptions hold true
in those set of situations using
generative models
is is going to be beneficial over using
logistic regression
however if you have lots of data
and you know you're you're not too sure
of whether
the modeling assumptions hold true or
not then you're better off using
logistic regression in logistic
regression we made no assumption
about the about how x's are distributed
we only model p of y given x
and x was assumed to be given so
logistic regression is in general
more robust to the kinds of
excess that that you may ah you may you
may actually encounter
however in examples where
the assumptions hold gda will be more
sample efficient
right you need a lot fewer examples when
the assumptions hold with gda as opposed
to logistic regression
and and that's that answer kind of holds
for you know all generative models
ah when you want to when you want to
learn
some kind of machine learning model
right so when you want to build a model
you can kind of give information to it
either through
assumptions or you can give it
information
from data right and
as long as your assumptions are true
feeding those assumptions is beneficial
and you have these other in this other
case so in in gda in these generative
models you're feeding in a lot more
assumptions a lot more prior knowledge
right and as long as those knowledge is
is uh as long as those assumptions is
is true it is beneficial you need a lot
less data to make up for
um for the information right in
discriminative models you are feeding a
lot fewer assumptions you are saying
nothing about
xs at all right which means you need to
make up for that
lack of information that you are feeding
by having more data
right and it it fits the data no matter
how you know
it fits the data better because you're
just making fewer assumptions about
how the data is supposed to be so that's
that's going to be a common
difference between or a common way to
think about when you want to use
generative models versus when you want
to use discriminator models
right so that was a gda then we
kind of moved on to naive bayes
right so naive bayes
in naive bayes so naive bayes is is an
algorithm that is commonly used with
text classification
right ah in text classification the
inputs or the xs are discrete you know
they are
discrete words that make up a sentence
or a message
and in naive bayes we kind of
saw these ah so first of all in naive
bayes we make this
conditional independence assumption the
conditional independence assumption
tells us that
x i is independent
of x j given y
which means if you know what the class
is whether you know for example if
you're doing spam classification
y can be zero or one uh spam versus no
spam if you know what the class is
then the probability of observing one
word is independent of the probability
of
observing another word right this
does not mean x i
is independent of x j right so
independence and conditional
independence are
two to ah kind of orthogonal properties
being conditionally independent says
nothing about being independent and vice
versa
right in in naive bayes we make this
conditional independence assumption
that if we know the class then the
probability of one word occurring
is independent of the probability of
other words occurring
right and this this assumption may or
may not hold true in practice
but but it so happens that even when
these assumptions are not met
the models tend to work reasonably well
with text
or textual data especially for
classification yes questions
oh sorry yeah
that doesn't hold and we saw
two two different event models called
the
ah bernoulli event model
bernoulli event model
and the and the multinomial event model
trinomial event
model right so the difference between
the these two is
in um in both of in both of uh um
both of these event models we assume p
of y
is equal to v y
p of y equals v y
right so this is the class prior
class prior
right so the class prior is what
fraction of all the messages that you
encounter
will be spammy in general right without
even looking at the messages
of the other content of the messages
that's just the class prior
and then in the bernoulli event model
we say p of
x j given y is equal to
phi j
given y according to ah
again this is a bernoulli distribution
bernoulli distribution
what that means is over here x j
is the jth word
in the vocabulary
right what this means is
we have one parameter per word in the
vocabulary per class
okay and the the
uh what the what the parameter signifies
is
the probability that of the word the jth
word in the vocabulary
occurs in a given message
so the ah on the on the on the
on the other hand with the multinomial
event model we have
p of x j given y
is equal to is was um
equal to phi
j given given y where this is the
is the jth multinomial distribution
parameter
or the categorical distribution
parameter multi-node
distribution and x j here refers to
the j-th word in a message
right so in the in the bernoulli event
model
we care about what fraction of the
message the word occurs versus does not
occur
we don't care how many times the word
occurs in that message
we're just we're just counting what
fraction of the messages does this word
occur versus not occur
it may occur 10 000 times in a message
but we just count it once that it
occurred in this message
whereas in the multinomial event model
we are trying to
build a histogram of of words
that occur in all the messages of a
given
of a given class right so um here
we basically end up counting the number
of times the word repeats
across all messages in spammy emails
and similarly the number of times a word
occurs across all messages
in non-spammy emails right and
and then we count them and normalize
them to get a multinomial distribution
over the words so that's a multinomial
element model whereas in a bernoulli
event model we kind of
treat each word in the vocabulary as a
separate problem
and estimates estimate the the bernoulli
parameter
of what fraction of messages does this
word occur in
in the spamming emails or not this
the way question think about it like can
you confirm this is a
right way basically multinomial is
the same as bernoulli but what you do is
you concatenate all the
non-spam messages and concatenate all
the spammy messages
uh that's not the case so uh um the the
the question was in uh in multinomial do
you think of it as taking all the
spamming messages concatenating it as
one big message
take all the you know non-smiley
messages concatenated against one big
message
take those two big messages and perform
bernoulli uh that's not the case
uh because in bernoulli we are only
we we are counting the number of times
or rather the number of messages in
which a word appears
so if you collapse everything into one
message then the answer is always zero
or one does that appear in that one
large message or not
whereas in in a multinomial what you
want to do is actually count the number
of times the word repeats across all
messages
right so the two the those two are are
need not be the same
right and then um we also saw this
concept called laplace moving
where in laplace smoothing is a
technique to handle
rare words where you know words may
occur very
infrequently and in laplace smoothing
the idea is
for each of the two different event
models
first kind of pre-count that each event
happens once
and starting with a count of one for
each of the events
then look at the data and in start
incrementing the counters
right that's that's the general idea of
of laplace smoothing where
you want to start with instead of
starting with the zero prior
where a zero prior means you have no
idea whether a message is you know a
word occurs in a spammy email or not
start with the prior where you assume
you've seen um
you know one one count of each event
right so that means uh in the in the
bernoulli case
each word assume that you've seen it
once in a spammy email and once in a
non-spammy email
then you start incrementing the counters
by looking at the emails
and seeing whether and checking whether
the word occurred in it or not
right and similarly in the multinomial
event model
assume that every word
occurs once in the spam
class or the spam pool of messages and
occurs once
in the non-spam pool of messages and
then construct the histogram of words
from you know this pool and that pool by
adding on to that one
right and then normalize it so that's
laplace moving
and that kind of wraps up generative
models
so those were basically the two models
that we saw gda and naive bayes gda was
for continuous access
naive bayes was for discrete access
and then ah after
after our generative models we moved on
to kernel methods
so
with kernel methods the
the motivation for kernel methods is
having some kind of an efficient way to
introduce feature maps
right so we saw feature maps in homework
one
the last question where we implemented
polynomial features
for linear regression and we saw that by
using feature maps
even though we are fitting a linear
model the hypothesis that we get
can be quite non-linear or quite curvy
so linear regression
is linear in its parameters or linear in
its
features it's not always linear in the
with respect to the original data
so by introducing these features we can
get you know a pretty complex
non-linear models and kernel methods
is a way to to ah
have these non-linear features in
an efficient way
so a kernel
in order to define a kernel we start
with the feature map
kernel methods
right so we start with the feature map v
of x
that takes from rd
to r p
right where x is in
rd that's the data that is given to you
right and
p is the
uh the dimension
of the feature space
and importantly p can be infinite
and now we define a kernel based on this
feature map
and say that a kernel corresponding to a
kernel is a function of two inputs
let us call it x and x prime
corresponding to a feature map
if it evaluates to v of x
transpose v of x prime right
so a kernel takes as input two axis like
you know before you map them to a
high dimensional feature space and it
evaluates
the output to have the same value
as that you would get by mapping them to
the high dimensional feature space and
taking an inner product
right so mathematically these two are
equivalent but computationally or
algorithmically
the kernel would generally perform some
kind of a more efficient computation
that gives you the same answer as if you
had constructed an explicit feature map
and done an inner product between them
right so those are kernels so kernels
are functions of
x and x prime corresponding to some
feature maps such that they evaluate to
you know mathematically evaluate to
the same answer as you would have
obtained from the explicit feature map
construction
and then um there are a few properties
of of uh kernels
so a function k is a kernel
if it is symmetric
if it is symmetric and
if you were to take a collection of
examples x 1 through ah
so if you were to take x 1 through let
us say
x let's call it m
and construct a kernel matrix so kernel
matrix is then
a matrix of m by m
right and these examples can be any
examples these need not be a training so
take any possible
examples you can you can ah come up with
and if you
evaluate k of x 1
x 1
k of x 1
x m and similarly
k of x m
x m k of x
m x one so evaluate the uh kernel
function
on every pairwise on every pair of uh uh
of of uh two two uh two choices from the
set
and this matrix that you obtain
where each of these is just a scalar and
each of these is a scalar
and you get this matrix which is also
called the kernel matrix
this kernel matrix will be symmetric and
positive semi definite
and we saw we also saw this ah
this theorem called mercer's theorem
versus theorem which says
in order for a function k to be a kernel
it is necessary and sufficient for the
corresponding kernel matrix to be
symmetric and positive semi different
right so the the um
so the kernel matrix being symmetric and
positive semi definite
is both a property of kernels which
means it is
a necessary condition and mercer's
theorem uh
tells us that it's also a sufficient
condition that for any k
if this property holds then k must be a
kernel function
right and the mercer's theorem um
you know one one loose intuition there
is the mercer's theorem is essentially
telling us that
um any sub matrix of a positive semi
definite matrix
is also positive semi definite so you
can think of kernels as these
uh psd functions which are infinite
dimensional
and a kernel matrix is you know
a choice of
for some choice of specific input values
evaluate the kernel
at those points and extract it into a
matrix and mercer's theorem essentially
tells you
that you know any sub matrix of this
infinite dimensional
psd matrix or psd function must also uh
um is necessarily p as a positive
semi-definite and vice versa yes
question
where does x1 it can be any x1 through
xm any arbitrary x1 through xm
any example they need not be a training
set it's just a property of this of this
uh function right
so that was that was uh kernels um
his question
so uh you know the the mercer's theorem
tells us that
so this infinite dimensional space that
you see you can think of this as the
function k
ah where this is one input the other
input and
the values here are the the values that
the function evaluates to
right and now uh think of this as an
infinite dimensional matrix right
and now if you just you know extract the
evaluations of this function
at certain points right so this
corresponds to
x one this corresponds to x two
you know and this corresponds to x m and
similarly this corresponds to x 1
you know x m right so basically you are
just extracting these
these extracting a sub matrix out of
this infinite dimensional matrix here
right and mrs theorem is uh is a is
another
uh is another way to say that
uh a matrix in this case the infinite
dimension matrix is positive semi
definite
if and only if any sub matrix is
positive similar
so that's that's ah that's mercer's
theorem and that's kernels
and the kernel trick is basically
if we can rewrite our algorithm
to be represented as inner products of
x's then we can replace those inner
products
with kernel functions right and
that basically allows us to redefine
parameters so if this
is our design matrix x where you have
n examples and
let us call it ah p features
so so this is phi of x right so this is
some feature map
and you have you have p features and
n examples right um
in the simplistic approach in in the in
the naive approach we would define
a theta vector
right so we would define a theta vector
in our p you know if
if you used a feature map p and then we
would use some kind of a gradient
descent
to keep updating these theta vectors
with each time step by minimizing a loss
right so think of this as theta at time
0 and then
theta at time 1 theta at time 2 and so
on and gradient descent gives us
updated theta vectors with the kernel
method
we can basically flip it around and say
we define one coefficient
per example so this
would be call it beta0
where we have one element per
example which kind of sets the weight of
that
example in a way right and with with
kernel methods
we keep obtaining these updated beta
vectors
um
right so gradient descent keeps helping
us from
here to here and similarly if you if you
kernelize it
you you um you work with coefficients
for different examples
right and this this method therefore
basically allows us
ah to have infinite dimensional
feature maps right the naive method
would start failing
as you extended p to infinity because
you need to maintain vectors of that
length
whereas with kernel methods we are
maintaining a vector
of length equal to number of examples
and so even
even this kind of allows you to use
infinitely
long feature maps and we
we use kernel the uh the kernel version
to evaluate the um
evaluate the infinite dimensional ah
inner products in some inexpensive way
and we maintain ah finite dimensional ah
coefficient vectors right so that is
that's a kernel that's the kernel trick
we um in the notes we have
we have uh described how to use the
apply the kernel uh kernel trick to
linear regression
and in one of the homework problems you
know the perceptron algorithm
right in the perceptron algorithm not
only did you kernelize it but you also
made it work in a streaming setting
where you are obtaining one example at a
time and the beta vector
would be extended as you keep and as you
kept encountering new examples
so the ah that was from kernelizing the
perceptron
right
and then we
we briefly covered support vector
machines so support vector machine is a
kernel based classification algorithm a
kernelized perceptron is also a kernel
based classification algorithm
the person the support vector machine
however focuses on something called as
the geometric margin
that defines the separating hyper plane
right the uh the
algorithms such as logistic regression
try to maximize the functional margin
which is different from the geometric
margin
and you saw the distinction between
functional margin and geometric margin
in the uh again in in pset to question
one on training stability of
of uh logistic regression where
logistic regression by trying to
maximize the functional margin
would keep extending the margin all the
way to plus infinity
because it found a well a hyperplane
that could be separated and it would
just
gain for free a higher functional margin
by just scaling all the values up and it
would just keep
scaling it forever whereas with support
vector machine you don't have such
problems
because you are trying to maximize the
geometric margin and the geometric
margin
is the geometric margin because it's a
geometric concept
right and the support vector machine
also has this other nice benefit
that the coefficient vector
that you end up with at the end of
training
is going to be sparse by sparse it means
that most of them will be zeros
except a few examples
the rest will all be zeros right and
these few examples
which have a non zero coefficient
are also called the support vectors
right so the idea there is
lets say you have you know some classes
over here
and another class over here with
examples
support vector machine tries to find
this
separating hyper plane that maximizes
the geometric margin between the two
classes
and in order to decide this this
exact position of the separating
hyperplane all what matters are these
nearest examples from both the classes
right
and these two these two subsets
of examples end up being the support
vectors
and the the uh the location of the other
examples don't matter so they get a
coefficient of zero
but the nearest examples end up having
non-zero coefficients
and those are also called the support
vectors right so support vector machines
are are are kind of this nice
they have this nice benefit that
you can use kernel methods and get
scalability in terms of features
to infinite dimensions but also
unlike other kernel methods where you
need to hold on to the
training the entire training set into
test time
support vector machines allow you to
hold on to just these few support
vectors
into test time right so so
the sparse dual coefficient so the
sparse
coefficients that you get from support
vector machines gives you this nice
benefit that
you get scalability in terms of number
of features
and also scalability in terms of number
of examples because you're only going to
hold on to you know a few support
vectors into test time
whereas with other kernel kernel methods
you generally need to hold on to the
entire
training set into test time so that was
a support vector machines
and then we moved on to another kind of
kernel algorithm called gaussian
processes
right gaussian processes so gaussian
processes is a kernel method
for regression right so support vector
machine and kernelized perceptron
were kernel methods for classification
right gaussian processes is a kernel
method
for regression
right and with gaussian processes the
the ah the way we we ah
define gaussian processes is to
generalize
gaussian distributions to infinite
dimensions
right and in infinite dimensions uh
so if we have a gaussian vector right of
you know of a certain dimension
that has a certain mean and a certain
covariance
in a gaussian process you have this
function where you are visualize where
we are
thinking a function as an infinitely
long vector
right so it's it's it's like a
continuous version of an array of of
of a vector which extends to infinity
right and this is a
gaussian process that has a mean
function
right which is again infinite dimension
and instead of a matrix
you have a covariance function k
right so a gaussian process is this
infinite dimension extension
of a multivariate gaussian distribution
okay and there are certain properties of
multivariate gaussian distribution that
makes
marginalization easy so if you want to
marginalize out
one of the one of the components of
a gaussian distribution you just ignore
that component in the mean
and ignore that row and column in the
covariance function right so
marginalization is very easy
in in gaussian distribution so one way
to think of
the way we apply gaussian processes to
um to a given data set is to
it is an incorrect ah technically
incorrect but
very useful in terms of understanding
that
you have this infinite dimensional
gaussian vector
and we marginalize out everything that
is outside
our training second test set right so
choose only those points in this
infinite
infinite dimensional vector choose
that finite subset of points where that
finite subset
is made up of examples in our training
set and examples in our test set
right and that basically kind of
condenses
this infinitely infinite long mean
function into a finite dimensional mean
vector
and an infinite you know a covariance
function
into a covariance matrix and this
covariance matrix that you that you
obtained
is exactly like this how you obtain a
kernel matrix
with kernel methods you obtain a
covariance matrix
by using the kernel function and we saw
that
a kernel matrix must always be positive
semi different moses theorem told us
and covariance functions or covariance
matrices need to be positive semi
definite so that kind of matches up
right and once we obtain this we just
use
the conditioning of gaussian
distributions
to condition on the training set and
obtain posterior on the
test set on on the examples that we want
to make prediction
right so that's that's gaussian process
the mathematical notation can be a
little
messy but uh essentially what's
happening there
is is just this right marginalize out
everything that's not necessary
and use the conditioning rules like the
rules themselves are heavy on notation
but you know you just plug the the uh
the
the correct pieces into the conditioning
rule and
you get your predictive distribution on
on unseen examples right so that is
gaussian processes
any questions on that
yeah good question so what kernel do we
use and generally the choice of kernel
is a hyper parameter that you tune
you try different kernels and see what
best what works best instead of
giving you good predictive power on a
validation set right you generally
you generally play around with a few
different kernels and and choose one
that works best for you
so the the choice of which kernel you
want to use
is somewhat equivalent to the question
of asking what feature map do you want
to use with linear regression it's it's
very similar
right so then we moved on to neural
networks
so with neural networks
i want to think of neural networks as
these complex
differentiable
layer wise or composite functions
that have parameters at all
layers with nonlinearities
right so imagine
you have given a feeding an input
vector x into a model right so this is x
in
rd and so we're going to be going to
talk about
what's commonly called as as a fully
connected networks
this is one specific architecture of
neural networks where you start with
the input x that you're feeding into
your model
and you take it through these
hidden layers
where from the input layer this is
called you know you can think of it as
layer 0
you go to hidden layer 1 by multiplying
this
by a matrix w
w x plus sum bias b
and
running all of these through some
non-linearity g
right so g of w x plus b will give you
this vector right so w
w is a parameter that you want to learn
right and x is the input that's going in
b
is another set of parameters that you
want to learn g is some
element wise non-linearity like the
sigmoid function for example
right and depending on the dimension of
w
right w will generally
be r uh let's let's uh um
um let's call this
k by d right so w x will therefore be
let's call it r k where this has a k
components and this had
d components in it
and then we basically ah perform perform
ah
another layer of the same so g of
so if this is w one you have another w
2 of of this
which let us call it a 1
plus b 2
right and so on eventually
we bring it down to one scalar which we
call it as y hat
right and then corresponding to this x
there is another y
so you take the output of the network
take the actual output
and combine the two into some kind of a
loss
right and this loss is a scalar
these these outputs and labels could
possibly be
be vectors so if you are doing
multi-class classification this would
give you
this would be like the output of soft
max so it would be a full vector
and the true true label would be a
one-hot vector of what the correct
answer is
right and but the loss is always a
scalar valued loss right that's that's
uh that's the common convention so you
start with the scalar value loss
and now we want to we want to calculate
the the the gradient
of this loss with respect to every
parameter and every layer
and in order to calculate that we use an
algorithm called back propagation
and back propagation is essentially just
the multivariate
uh chain rule of calculus right so
the way you want to think of back
propagation is
always start with one scalar parameter
let's say w
i j and
try to calculate the partial of loss
with respect to
partial of w i j of some layer
l right and this
will always must always evaluate to a
scalar because you're calculating the
the gradient of a scalar with respect to
a scalar
and the intermediate steps to calculate
this
will involve you know going from the
scalar to a vector
and from vector to vector vector to
vector and finally vector to scalar
right and so um
and each of those intermediate
components are called jacobians
right going from vector to vector and
and
so each of those intermediate um are
called jacobians
and you will encounter you will
generally see that
the c the chain of jacobians that you
encounter while calculating uh this
will generally be you know you have a
row vector
matrix matrix matrix
and finally a column vector right
and once once you once you multiply them
out this will just evaluate to a scalar
this this is this is going to be common
and for layers where you're
performing a non-linearity the jacobian
will be a diagonal matrix and for
computational reasons
you you know you you might want to
instead of
implementing as a diagonal matrix you
might just want to do element wise
multiplication
right so perform this for every possible
parameter in the network and then you
can use some
you can identify common patterns and
define
update rule for the entire matrix in a
more compact
compact form right and so so all all
that is basically just algebraic
manipulation
but the goal that we are trying to
achieve is to calculate the gradient
of the loss which is scalar with respect
to
every scalar parameter right and once
once you calculate these gradients
it is basically just gradient descent
right perform gradient descent on all
these parameters simultaneously take a
small step
to minimize the loss with respect to all
these parameters and take a small step
and you know repeat until you converge
so that was neural networks and back
propagation
and after neural networks we moved on to
some learning theory basically
bias variance analysis
so bias variance analysis is probably
the most important concept from from the
entire course
and it's this bias variance analysis
that distinguishes machine learning
from say you know optimization right
in in general optimization problems you
are given some kind of a function or an
objective
and you want to maximize or minimize it
right and
we use such optimization techniques like
gradient methods newton's method
um or even just closed form expressions
for maximizing or minimizing
some kind of a loss right but what
distinguishes machine learning
from just optimization is the bias
variance trade off
which means uh what what it actually
means is our
end goal is not really minimizing the
training objective itself yes we are we
are minimizing the training objective
but our goal really is to perform well
on unseen data
right and we are kind of doing this
minimization of the
training loss as a proxy with the hope
that we're going to do well on test data
right so the the uh
bias variance analysis is is a way to
kind of
decompose our test error or the
encounter the the
error that we encounter at test time and
break it down
into sub components uh for bias various
and irreducible error
right so irreducible error uh and this
decomposition generally
holds true for all losses but in this in
in the specific case of a squared error
loss
we get a very clean decomposition that
mean squared error
you know on test set or on a test
example
is the sum of irreducible error
plus y square
plus variance
right the the fundamental assumption is
that our data is noisy
right and this noise can can
ah can affect our test error in two ways
so first of all
the test example that we are going to
encounter itself is going to be noisy
right and so the noise in the test
example contributes to
irreducible error right so this is noise
in test example
this basically tells us that no matter
what model you choose
right choose the best possible model
that can possibly be you know
possibly be imagined even that model
is going to encounter some error at test
time because your test data itself is
noisy
right so that's irreducible error no
matter what model you get you're going
to
you're going to pay this irreducible
error penalty no matter what
and then the bias and variance
are basically so you can think of the
the noise in the training data that you
have
to be contributed to be contributing to
to variance
so training
data noise
contributes to
the variance of the model right
and bias is more or less ah kind of
telling you
how inflexible your model is right so
your data may be
maybe saying some story of course a
noisy story of
how of of of the pattern between your
x's and y's
but the model that you have may be
limited to just linear models
even though your data has a clear let's
say you know
quadratic relationship x and y
where there's a clear quadratic linear
relationship between x's and y's if you
happen to choose linear models
then obviously your model is biased
because you're limited to solutions that
look like this
right so so bias is mostly due to
um inflexibility in your
in your model class
inflexibility
or limited capacity
of model class
and variance is due to noise in in your
our training data
right and so our goal
is to not minimize the training loss
but our goal is to actually minimize the
test class
right or the test error and this test
error
has one component called irreducible
error for which we can do nothing about
so we focus on just bias and variance
right
and the the kind of action space that we
have
includes kind of contradictory actions
right so
some action you know one action is you
know increased regularization
and increasing regularization will
reduce variance
but there is also another action called
reduce regularization
which will which will which will uh
fight bias
so in order to decide which action you
want to take you want to get a good
sense
of what is the contribution of bias
versus what's the contribution of
variance
in your test error and a loose proxy for
that
is you can think of
bias as training error
and variance as
gap between
test or validation
and training error
right so bias technically is not the
training error
but for the purposes of choosing the
action to take
it works as a sufficient proxy to think
of
a bias as training error so if your
training error is very high
then you want to take steps that fight
bias so in that way
it's it's a reasonable proxy for the
purposes of the bias variance analysis
to think of bias as the training error
and the variance is the gap between the
the test and
test or validation and training error
right and we we also discussed some
some actions ah in in the in the uh in
the previous
class of what what what actions help
fight bias versus what action
helps fight variants and before you take
any action you always always want to get
a breakdown of test error and train
error
and and ah kind of make a judgment call
of whether
you're facing a high bias problem or
facing a high variance problem
and accordingly take an action that will
reduce your overall test error
right so that's that's bias variance
problem and this methodology
this bias variance way of thinking holds
for classification
words for regression also supervised
words for unsupervised
it and it is it is it is kind of this
this topic that permeates all of all the
models and all the algorithms that we
consider
and it's probably the most useful when
you're applying your model of applying
machine learning for a new problem that
you're working on in practice because
the new
the new algorithm that you're working on
in practice might be you know an
algorithm that you
that we have not studied in this class
for example random forests
but you can apply bias variance for that
algorithm as well it works for all
algorithms
right so that was that was a bias
variance analysis
then we studied regularization
and gave a bayesian
interpretation for regularization right
so
regularization
is a way in which you add a penalty for
large values of your parameters
where the intuition is that large values
of parameters
can result in very complex models
and in order to kind of minimize the
complexity of our models we want to
limit
the the the values or the magnitudes of
our parameters
and so we if our um
so our loss now if it is generally some
kind of i equals 1
i equals 1 to n let us say y
i minus h theta of x
i square if this is our regular loss
we want to augment it with some kind
of a penalty for the loss
for for the parameters being too large
right
and you can either there are several
choices here
you may sometimes want to penalize the
one norm
of the of the parameters and we
we saw that adding adding the two norm
for the parameters is equal is has this
bayesian interpretation
of performing map estimation
with gaussian prior
right and with one ah with with the one
norm is equivalent to performing
m a p estimation with the laplace prior
right
and in your homework you also saw how to
how you know what the exact
value of these lambda terms should be
depending on the parameters of the
gaussian and laplace distribution
right so that was regularization
and after that we moved on to
reinforcement learning
right reinforcement learning is this
this
is slightly different from the other
algorithms in the sense that
in the other algorithms we make this iid
assumption where for each prediction
each prediction or each example is
completely
independent of another example on which
we are making a prediction
instead in reinforcement learning we are
in this sequential decision making
situation where the predictions that we
make
at one ah at one situation
will chew will will will result in some
action being taken
and that action will decide the next
state that we are end up with
and therefore decide the next situation
where our prediction is being made right
so the examples if you think of each
time step
in in reinforcement learning as an
example these examples are not iid
anymore they are all kind of correlated
and in order to formalize reinforcement
learning
we define something called an mdp or a
markov decision process
that is a tuple of states actions
transition probabilities psa in fact a
set
of transition probabilities a discount
factor and a reward function
right so the reward function so we can
be in one of
the many states which is defined by the
set
s we can take one of the many actions
defined by the set of actions a and
depending on which state we are and what
action we take
we end up in a new state and that
transition or the dynamics of
moving to the next state is captured by
this
uh the set of transition probability
vectors psa
and at each state when we arrive at a
state
we obtain a reward that is defined by
the reward function
and there is this discount factor called
gamma which which basically tells
the rewards that are obtained sooner or
better than rewards obtained later
right and gamma is generally a value
between 0 and 1.
so this is the the formalism in which we
we ah we attack the reinforcement
learning problem
and based on this mdp we define these
two
um kind of related concepts called value
and policy
right so value and policy
so policy is a mapping
from state to action
right its like a rule book if you are in
a particular state
what is the action that we should take
right this rule book is called the
policy
and the value v
that corresponds to a policy pi
of a given state is basically telling us
if we were to start in a state s
and were to continue the trajectory by
taking
actions according to the policy pi
right which means when you are in state
s take action according to
you know the value pi of s evaluates to
and that action according to the
dynamics is going to take to a random
new state
and in that new state which is random
refer to the rule book and take an
action according to that policy
right and so on and if we were to repeat
this
this pro this process over and over
where each time
you know you you can end up in a
different state according to the
dynamics
what is the average accumulated sum of
discounted rewards and that is
is is captured by this function called v
pi
this question
just the concepts of policy and value
right so policy is just a rulebook
right and value is the is the long-term
reward that you're going to accumulate
by starting at s and following the
rulebook y
right and and these two concepts
you know policy and value
are kind of related so
if you are given a policy pi you can
perform something called as policy
evaluation
and get v pi
or v pi
right and to get v pi you can you can
you can obtain v p using
a simple uh set of linear linear
equations you can just solve a linear
equations and get
the values for for all the different
states and
if you are at if if you're given some
policy v
that policy kind of implicitly defines
i think i said it wrong if you are given
a value function v
that value function v implicitly defines
a policy but the policy
is to take action in a greedy way to
maximize the
value of the next state right so
um so so pi
of s is equal to
arg max of a
expectation of
v of
s prime where s prime
comes from p s a
right choose an action that is going to
maximize
the expected value of the next state
right
so value implicitly defines a policy
and a policy defines a value
however the subtlety is that this cycle
is not is is is
is not the inverse of the other
direction which means a policy will will
give you
a particular value function but then if
you take this value function
and try to calculate the policy that
that um
acts greedily according to this value
function
you will not get the same policy again
right and that asymmetry
is what is captured in policy iteration
so policy iteration
is an algorithm where we start with a
random policy
evaluate the corresponding value
function and take that evaluation
value function and re-estimate the best
possible policy you can come up
and then re reevaluate the new policy
the the new value function according to
the policy and go on and on until you
converge
right so that's policy policy uh
iteration
until your policy converges
and then there is this other other
algorithm called value iteration
in value iteration
we have this this ah thing called the
the bellman equation
right in the and the goal
in in in in the
value iteration is to estimate this
function called v star which is called
the optimal value function
and v star of s is basically
you know r max
of phi of v
of s so basically
now what is the best possible value
that you can have for a given state if
you were to
scan across all possible policies right
so that's that's
the optimal value function
and this optimal value function if you
were to plug it here
the policy that you're going to recover
is the optimal policy
right next question
yeah you're right this should this
should just be yeah you're right thank
you so this just should be a max right
so the the idea with uh
uh with with value iteration is that uh
value iteration
has you perform this update rule
where v of s set it equal to
v of s plus um
sorry r plus
plus um gamma times
max a
yes
thank you right so this this is uh
this is also called the uh the bellman
backup operator
where if you were to perform this over
and over you will recover v star
and the intuition to have here is
if this is the space of all value
functions so this is a v of
s 1 through v of
s s
right all the possible value functions
there is this optimal
v star and no matter where you start
right so you you can call this as ah
this operator as
you know v is equal to bellman operas
of v right so take any two value ah or
any two value functions
run both of them through the bellman
operator
right now the distance between these two
will always be smaller than the distance
between
the original two right this distance
will always be smaller
which means the bellman backup operator
or the bellman operator
is a contraction mapping right so the
space is getting
um if if you were to run your examples
over and over
with these bellman operators then they
are kind of converging
right and whenever you have a
contraction mapping there exists
this point called the fixed point
right and this fixed point
is the the optimal value function
right so the uh um the value iteration
takes your value function from any space
from any point in the space
you keep applying the bellman operator
you are going to eventually
converge to the fixed point right so
that is that is a
value iteration running this over and
over
and we we also saw this
other um
we also saw a variant of this called
fitted value iteration
right so fitted value iteration where in
we we limit ourselves
so supposing this is v star we limit
ourselves
to a class of value functions
right in this class of value functions
let's say this this could be
the class that is like the output of a
neural network or a linear model
you know any any any uh some class of
value functions
where we start with some point
you know some theta that that
parameterizes this
value function and on this we apply the
bellman backup operator
the bellman backup operator will take us
to some new
value function which may be outside our
parameter space
right and then we project this back onto
so this this bellman operator take
operator takes us here
and then we project it back onto our
class by by
trying to fit this this ah
value function from a function in our
class
say you know say by minimizing the least
square or
some such loss function right so that's
like projecting this new function back
into the class and from here again apply
the bellman
operator you get a new function project
it back
right you can apply the bellman operator
right and then project it back right and
this is called the fitted value
iteration
where you are staying within this
parameter
this parameterized family of functions
right
and the iteration takes you closer and
closer to to v star
right but this algorithm is not
guaranteed to converge
right because this is not a true
contraction mapping anymore right there
is no there is no
there is no fixed point for this and
but however in practice it it tends to
work well
okay so that's that's a fitted value
iteration
we um in in your homework
you implemented uh value iteration for
the inverted pendulum problem
and we did not do fitted value iteration
in the homework implemented this
and you also implemented this in the
context where
psa was not known right so in the in the
homework
by by running your simulator we also
learned the transition probabilities
as a separate problem and using the the
estimated
transition probabilities we learned the
uh val we performed the value iteration
this question
what would a fitted
yeah so how would fitted value iteration
look in code so in co
in in the homework you represented value
as
some vector right whose length was
the number of states you had right in um
which meant you could set each element
of this value function freely to any
value
right you could you could set this and
not worry about what value was here
right in fitted value iteration
you are no longer representing your
value function explicitly as an array
but instead you will have you
v of s will be some some let's call it
h theta of s so s will be the input to
the model the output of the model
will be the corresponding value
right so this is fitted value iteration
initially
when we were doing value iteration was
we were using the bellman backup
operator to get v star
but now we are trying to fit some theta
exactly so initially with
with with bellman backup operator we
directly work with this array
and apply the bellman backup operator
until this entire array converges
right with fitted value iteration uh we
describe the algorithm
in the class and it's also in the notes
we
we limit ourselves to a representation
like this it's no longer an explicit
array
right and on this we we apply the
bellman
backup operator obtain something called
y
right and then find a new theta
nu theta uh
arg min of
h theta of s minus y
square something like this right so we
are kind of projecting
the y back to the theta space
exactly so this could be a linear model
where you represent your value as theta
transposes
yeah so you kind of lose flexibility but
you also gain generalization
so if you do well on one state and
another state is very similar
then you kind of have a good sense of
the value of the other state
just because two states are similar
whereas with an explicit array
representation there's no hope of
generalization whatsoever
so on policy off policy is not relevant
for the for the
review so we have we still have a few
more topics maybe i can talk about on
policy of policy later
right so so after reinforcement learning
we moved on to unsupervised learning
where in unsupervised learning
the we are given
a set of examples xs but there is no
corresponding y
and our our task is to learn some
interesting structure
and the structure we saw
uh in in the class basically we we
looked at two kinds of structures
the first one is do the examples
cluster in some way right and
k means was the first algorithm that we
saw and in k
means the idea is you are given
you know some set of
some data set you know x one
through x d right and
given this data set um that's all what
you're given there are no labels
you know we don't have a y value that
tells this the all these are class 1
class 2 class 3 that
we don't have any of that right and our
goal is to now kind of
cluster them in some way
right and those were clustering
algorithms
and there is this other kind of
unsupervised learning
ah where we are interested in finding
subspaces
x one and x d right
if this is our set of examples x's there
is no y's given to us
right in in in clustering we are trying
to group
examples into different categories right
whereas in subspace finding problems we
are trying to see if this
high dimensional representation can be
instead
captured in a lower dimensional
representation so this data
can be projected on to a one dimensional
representation that pretty much captures
all the variants right and this was in
pca
right so we had these
you know unsupervised learning we had
clustering plot
problems and subspace binding problems
right and
in in in the two the two that we spoke
about just now you know k
means and pca
we call them non-probabilistic
non-probabilistic so
k means and pca
and we have probabilistic equivalents
right for clustering we use the gaussian
mixture model
and for subspace finding we used factor
analysis
the the rough intuition to have is
think of clustering as the unsupervised
version
of classification and subspace finding
as the unsupervised
version of regression like that's that
that's a lose-lose
lose analogy there right and we use we
also saw this algorithm called
e m or expectation maximization that we
applied
to solve the probabilistic versions you
know both gmm and factor analysis
using this algorithm called expectation
maximization
right in expectation maximization which
is really an important
algorithm especially if you want to get
into machine learning research
um you know in in you know some of the
new hot topics like you know deep
generative models
it's very important that you have a good
understanding of expectation
maximization and all its variants
ah because that's that's really where
things kind of start off
right so in em we have
parameters for a model so we we start
with a model
where here by model we mean some kind of
a probabilistic model
x comma z with some parameters theta
which has parameters
theta and
we call the observed components of
our model as evidence so evidence
is generally denoted as x and we the
other
unobserved elements of the of the ah
of the model are called latent variables
we call them z right and in e m
what we do is this um iterating it em is
an iterating algorithm
where each iteration has two steps
the e step we calculate the posterior
now q of z i is equal to
p of z i given
x i at the current value of theta and in
the m
step
right we update thetas to r max theta
of
expectation of z according to q i
of log p
of x z theta
over q i of z
right so here the arg max theta
the theta that we are optimizing appears
only here
okay and
and by by performing this this over and
over
um this term is also called the elbow
right by performing this over and over
we saw that this algorithm will
eventually converge
we saw a proof of convergence of the em
algorithm
um and and uh this this this algorithm
will
uh um eventually converge right so that
was that was
uh em algorithm the
we also saw another another ah model
called ica
independent component analysis we used
it to
um use it to solve the source separation
problem in
audio right you did that in your last
homework where you're given
some some mixture of different signals
you make a non gaussian assumption about
the sources of those signals
and using those non gaussian assumption
you are able to construct
a unmixing matrix and that unmixing
matrix
is calculated using maximum likelihood
right and
the the unmixing matrix that you obtain
will be able to separate your audio
sources
into distinct distinct original
audio components right so we saw this in
the homework
and in in again in your homework in the
em algorithm
we saw an extension of this for
semi-supervised learning
right so it's it's uh i would say it's
pretty important to kind of understand
that step
that leap from unsupervised to semi
supervised how we went
and try to get a real sense of you know
what the what the moving parts was in
the proof for
moving from from from unsupervised uh to
uh
semi-supervised
and what else that's that's pretty much
that we that that we covered in this
course then we also uh um
in in the last few lectures we saw the
variational autoencoder
uh again in the variational autoencoder
we are um
the variation autoencoder is probably
not not not going to be in your exam but
you know it's an important concept
especially
those who want to go into research where
we have the z
the latent variable and
x the evidence
in e m we would construct a q
for each example the posterior whereas
with the variational autoencoder we
construct an encoder
network neural network that takes x as
input
and outputs z as the output
and given the latent variable to the
evidence
in in case of for example simple models
we call this
the likelihood function
right but in in the v a we call this the
decoder network
right
and we train the um so again just like
we saw in the in the in the fitted value
iteration
right in in the original em each example
got its own
q function right for the for the
posterior
and each cube of each example could be
set independently and freely
whereas with the variational auto
encoder we are trying to come up with
this class
now just you know have a similar picture
in your mind you're trying to represent
all the posteriors with some kind of a
class right and which is called a
amortized inference
where instead of calculating a separate
posterior for each you construct this
class where you feed x as the input and
the output will be the parameters of the
corresponding
q distribution right
that's that's uh and then in the last
lecture we covered evaluation metrics
evaluation metrics are we don't have
time to review them in um
in today's lecture but they are pretty
pretty straightforward you can just look
at the slides
so that completes uh pretty much the the
course review
um we've covered a lot of material in
this course
another few few kind of uh ending
remarks
so with all the kind of techniques that
you've learned here
right you can use these techniques for
lots of different purposes
right your interests might be in
research your interest might be more
applied
a general kind of
ending note is to is to kind of
recognize the power that machine
learning has you can build really
powerful algorithms using
machine learning but hopefully you know
also put some thought
into the problems that you're trying to
solve with these algorithms
machine learning is a great tool it
gives you a lot of power which means
you know it can be used for good and it
can be abused
right always put some thought into um
before you jump into a problem and try
to solve a problem using machine
learning
to think of what the possible side
effects could be right so machine
learning
um is at the end of the day it is
it it it looks for correlation among
examples it has no sense of causality
right and so the the problems that
that are there with correlation you know
as opposed to causation transfer over to
machine learning
in you know um with this with the same
readers and
restrictions so um any bias that is
there in your data set will transfer
over into your predictions by bias
i don't mean bias and variance but you
know any other kinds of bias
and and fairness issues that may be
there in in
in the data set that you've collected
which may be coll which
which may be you know not purely sampled
all those issues will transfer over to
the predictions that you make
right so always be skeptical about the
way your data was collected
and especially if you're going to build
some kind of
a pipeline where actions are being taken
depending on the predictions that you're
made you need to be especially even more
skeptical about your model
right at the same time the
you know machine learning can be applied
in lots of different fields
any field that collects data and needs
predictions you can use machine learning
there which means
the scope of application of machine
learning is tremendous
and probably a good fraction of you
might be interested in machine learning
research but probably
most of you are interested in applying
machine learning to different different
areas
so the hope is that you know the lessons
that you've learned
in this in in this course uh especially
the different set of tools that you
learned as different models and also the
general principles like bias variance
analysis will help you
solve these problems in your respective
fields right
and for those of you who are interested
in machine learning research right now
machine learning research is super hard
there are lots of scope for for doing um
you know
cutting edge bleeding edge research in
machine learning
um so good luck for those of you who are
who are
interested in doing research happy to
chat about research offline
and to kind of uh wrap things up uh i
hope you enjoyed this course i hope you
uh enjoyed the material uh and uh that
we've kind of
covered i personally enjoy teaching this
course a lot i
i myself learned a lot in by you know by
just going through the process of
teaching
i pro you know the half of machine
learning what i know as of today half of
it probably i learned them in the last
two months uh
in the process of uh preparing for the
lectures um
and good luck on your finals um you know
the finals is
is designed to be hard so you know study
study hard
it's not long but you know it can be
tricky uh
yeah with that uh we'll we'll we'll kind
of end the last lecture
uh thanks everyone